foreign
[Music]
good evening
hi everyone welcome welcome to the table
thanks Jesse
the only one I heard said welcome back
thank you my name is Karen Miner and I
am part of the leadership team here at
the table and I'm so glad you're here
especially those of you who are new to
the table maybe tonight is your first
visit thank you for having the courage
to walk through those doors that can be
tough sometimes to come into a new place
like this so we really really appreciate
it we hope you feel warmly welcomed here
tonight we have quite a few things to
celebrate so first of all happy pride
month to everybody we love pride month
around here
and also happy Juneteenth Juneteenth is
the yeah
Juneteenth is the second Independence
Day of our country and it's an important
one it's actually observed officially
tomorrow if you were not aware of what
Juneteenth is and its significance to
our country and especially Texas take a
little time and Google it this week
and last but not least Happy Father's
Day to our dads
and our father figures
um so this past week I reached out to
some of our amazing table dads and this
includes dads who are
dads of little kids dads of tweens and
teens dads of adult kids
um
single dads blended family dads gay bi
and straight dads younger dads and
grayer dads
and I asked them to finish this sentence
being a dad is
and this is what they shared with me
being a dad is sometimes terribly
painful and heart-wrenching other times
it's the greatest gift ever
being a dad is hard have you met my kids
being a dad is leading with love and
with strength
being a dad is waking up every day and
choosing to put your family before
yourself
being a dad is hands down the greatest
joy and the greatest challenge the most
refining ego squashing process I have
ever journeyed through sounds like that
resonates with some of you for the first
time in my life I am understanding what
it means to lay down my life for someone
else and it is a mysteriously wonderful
experience it's just as Jesus said if
you give up your life for me you will
find it
being a dad is like getting the best
thing in the world in the most
overwhelming way imaginable
being a dad is one of the great honors
of my life
being a dad is the jarring feeling of
taking a sip of water when you thought
you ordered a Coke
being a dad is realizing everything that
frustrates you about your child is
something they learned from you
being a dad is the discovery that there
is so much more love inside you than you
ever thought possible
being a dad is tickle fights awkward
jokes
unconditional love watching them grow
letting go just being there and never
giving up
let's pray
God thank you for today
thank you for our dads here in this room
and those watching online thank you for
the dads that are no longer with us
I also pray your blessings over those
for whom Father's Day is difficult and
complicated and hard and challenging a
mix of emotions
God I pray your comfort would surround
them surround us around me
and God just thank you for tonight speak
to our hearts open our hearts and help
us to trust you at deeper levels and to
love you God as just the great parent
figure that you are in Jesus name amen
thank you Karen if you guys want to
stand with us we're going to start out
with a few songs and appropriately our
first song is titled the father's house
I once had somebody uh I was I was in
like a staff meeting at um
I worked at a church and and this guy
had come in to kind of do some like
coaching with us and and he had us
praying and he had Us close our eyes and
he said
can you imagine God like a dad
and you know we all have probably been
in situations if you've been in the
church very long where you know it's
like God the Father a familiar phrase
um and and then he said but what if this
dad was never disappointed in you and it
kind of struck me differently
um and I had an amazing dad he was an
incredible dad he is an incredible dad
um so it wasn't like my dad had
necessarily like screwed up this you
know potential to see a Father's Heart
in God but
um as an Enneagram one and a very loud
self-critic voice in my head I'm always
afraid of disappointing him or others
and it was this freedom to interact with
God in this way where it was just love
it was just you know even if you were at
your worst it was just this encompassing
love and the chorus of this song is so
fitting
um I feel like for that peace of God
that is that should be um like a father
to us just on Mother's Day we talked
about God our mother and today I want us
to kind of sink into the possibility of
God as a father who is not disappointed
in us but is on our side loving us
guiding us she sharing the journey both
good and bad with us so Gary's gonna
lead us in this one so you guys sing
along as you can
[Music]
sometimes on this journey get lost in my
mistakes what looks to me like weakness
is again so strength my story isn't over
my story's just begun
fear you won't Define me that's what my
father does I feel you won't Define me
that's what my father does
[Music]
[Applause]
never want it perfect anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
alone
glory in the father's house
[Music]
just find Hope
Love Is On The Move when the father's in
the room wide
[Music]
Miracles take place
oh you're in the father's house
[Music]
all right
all right you kiddos are dismissed to
your classrooms
I believe it's six
five and four over here and then all of
our older elementary kids on this right
side
[Music]
thank you Katie and L Eve Jill
and any other kids ministry workers
Angie potentially
you guys are such a gift to our
community the way that you serve and
love our kiddos and I know it's not
always easy so I appreciate you guys so
much
foreign
[Music]
as they get settled we're going to move
into the prayers of the people and if
this is your first time here just know
that this is a space where we want to
hold each other's burdens together
support one another and make room and
space for the things that we're carrying
on our hearts so we're going to read a
prayer out loud together and then we'll
leave space for you to speak the name or
situation that you might be carrying if
you're online feel free to leave that in
the comments and then we will wrap up
with another prayer at the very end that
we will read aloud
all right will you guys join me in this
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth that you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and the orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the vulnerable of the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
Noah and Gianna
and reasons
[Music]
foreign
for the names and the moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace
deep sense of your presence
[Music]
my life is yours
and my hope is in you holy
and my heart you hope
cause you made this sinner holy
[Music]
oh holy
your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
I fall onto my knees and off
a heartbeat of my life is to Worship in
your
Your Glory
of
your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
missing my life
my life is
[Music]
yours My Hope Is
oh
[Music]
cause your glory is so beautiful
I fall until my knees
and the heartbeat of my life is to
Worship in your life your glory is so
beautiful
your glory is so beautiful
oh
[Music]
foreign
glory and Glory
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
yes God
First Corinthians 1
the sun is the image of the invisible
God
the first born over all creation
for in him all things were created
things in heaven and on Earth
visible and invisible
whether Thrones or powers or rulers or
authorities all things have been created
through him and for him he is before all
things
and in him all things hold together
[Music]
with no point of reference you spoke to
the dark and fleshed Out The Wonder of
life
[Music]
and as you speak
a hundred billion galaxies are born
in the vapor of your breath the planet
if the stars were made to worship so
light
I can see your heart in everything you
made
[Music]
every burning star a signal fire of
Grace
if creation sings your praise is
so
[Music]
alive
the ones you have spoke
all Nature and Science follow the sound
of your voice
and as you speak
[Music]
a hundred million creatures
evolving in pursuit of what you said
if it all reveals
[Music]
in everything you say
every pain in the sky is
if your creations
[Music]
the oceans
with everything is
[Music]
we'll sing again
blood of Salvation
you chase down my heart through all of
my failure and pride
[Music]
on a hill you create
in the light of the world abandoned in
darkness to die
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
surrender so alive
[Music]
like you would again in a hundred
billion times
[Music]
beautiful
you never leave us behind
[Music]
God you're always faithful
you are always constant
[Music]
always present to us in our need
you are a good father
[Music]
you are sacrificial love
you are Redemption
you are Grace
you are Justice
you are righteousness
you are Beauty
God tonight we sink into your presence
we breathe in that nature
that character
those values of your kingdom that keeps
showing up again and again and again
the ones that follow us all the days of
our life
that keep returning and calling us back
home
that keep loving even when we have lost
our way
[Music]
that keep making space and room for more
the inclusive beautiful love of God
[Music]
would we connect to that tonight
would we find you ever present and close
[Music]
in Jesus name amen
thank you guys again for being with us
if you want to sit and as you do turn to
the people around you welcome them make
them feel seen and known and then Brett
will get us started on our message
oh Grace and peace
it is so good to be with you all so so
good and
um my name is Brett I'm the pastor here
at the table and I want to welcome all
of you and
um that includes those joining us online
as always love you all lots and um and
anyone here who is new thank you for
being Among Us I know it can be a
nerve-wracking experience coming into a
new community so we just want you to
know that you really are wanted and
welcome here and um you don't need to
feel I don't know out of place or
intimidated or something
um we are just regular people we're just
trying to love Jesus so um thank you for
being in our midst
um so we are in uh this is part two in
our series titled Sticks and Stones
rethinking the church's stance on sexual
orientation and gender and uh this is
kind of a series we like to do every few
years
um just to kind of help us process you
know this is
um well historically there's been you
know certain passages
um in the scriptures that have been used
and interpreted in ways that ended up
whether people meant it to or not the
the end result was very much a Sticks
and Stones
um kind of result and we all you know
know that that phrase sticks and stones
may break my bones but words will never
hurt me is uh they all lie because words
do hurt and and scripture is
um it is powerful it is uh even as it
self claims it's like a a two-edged
sword
um and yet we've got to be we've gotta
wield that carefully you know like with
wisdom and and being careful like what
are the results of our theology what are
the results of our interpretation we'll
get in actually the last message will be
about the the fruit
um Jesus said you'll know a tree by its
fruit meaning you'll know uh I would say
kind of the the
um the goodness of a tree of theology by
the fruit it produces you know is it is
it goodness and beauty and truth and
wholeness and healing
um or or is it something different you
know and um so that's kind of in the
series we're just um taking time to just
see if we can hear kind of a fresh word
uh from Christ on all this so um in
light of that the title of my message uh
tonight is sameness
sameness and our text is
from Genesis chapter two
verses 20 through 24
and it says these words so the man gave
names to all the livestock
the birds in the sky all the wild
animals but for Adam no suitable helper
was found
said Lord God caused the man to fall
into a deep sleep and while he was
sleeping he took one of the man's ribs
and then closed up the place with flesh
the first surgery I guess something
made a woman from the rib he had taken
out of the man and he brought her to the
man the man said this is now bone of my
bones
Flesh of My Flesh he shall be called a
woman for she was taken out of man that
is why a man leaves his father and his
mother and he's United to his wife and
they became or they become one flesh
so one of the great joys of my my work
as a pastor is that I I get to like
track people's lives you know closely
like they you know we often kind of live
guarded hopefully it can be different
here
um in the church if we should be able to
be real and vulnerable in any space Lord
knows it should be a church you know and
um so we're trying to kind of live into
that here and but this was one when I
worked in the kind of corporate world
for many years uh in between my two
pastoral stints and that was one of the
things that drove me bananas was you
know it's just a different setting you
know I can't be like so how are you good
good doing great how are you really I
couldn't do that you know what I mean
because they're just like you know um
but even though in my heart wanted to
like I'm just I guess I've always been a
pastor you know I wanted those real
conversations and so that's one thing I
love about my job is um in this this
role is being able to like ask you know
like how are you and people will share
and open up and so because of that I get
attract not only like you know and
individual Journeys but often couples
and even you know like married couples
and at the beginning though like eight
years ago was when I kind of came back
into the Pastoral Ministry and I was in
kind of theologically I was in what's
known as an open and affirming place I
mean I
um supported and celebrated same-sex
unions and
um but at that point I had really no
experience like you know counseling
same-sex couples and this was something
I was very nervous about
um because I just I didn't you know sort
of the one of those things where like
well you don't know what you don't know
and so I didn't know like would it be I
don't know like maybe super different
you know like I don't know it was like a
um kind of a gay male couples that like
different like is the relational
Dynamics wildly different you know than
say like a lesbian couple or versus
straight out you know whatever and I
just I I didn't know and I was like real
nervous and
um
so I've kind of you know journeyed
walked with many couples now and I'm
happy to report it turns out people are
just people
and all of my worries it was like all
utterly misguided like it just it just
any of people are just people
relational struggles it's like all the
same stuff I mean mostly honestly most
of the time we're bumping into ourselves
you know like the people trigger things
but it's like kind of in us and it's
often our own stuff to work through and
we're all like dealing with our own
fears and traumas and paths and you know
I mean like we're all just working
through it and then we bring that into
the relationship and then we try to work
it through as couples that's always the
challenge of the couple is like so let
me bring all of my baggage and then all
of yours I'm like bring this together
and it'll be great you know um it is
it's just but it but it really was it
was like lo and behold
People Are People
and um that what's interesting though
is you can even see it in my own kind of
mindset back then and and even the way
we think of like personality and such we
often
um think of like marital relationships
or even romantic relationships of any
sort
um as very much about what we might call
just difference
and kind of what I mean is like in in
the sense of well I kind of build our
Theology and our ways of thinking about
like you know
um couples in this different thing now
this can play out like personality
people often have quite elaborate
theories honestly about like personality
differences
and you know like what will mesh and
what will not mesh you know and uh this
seems to me to get a little kind of out
there you know where we have like these
complicated theories of like okay so
like if you're extroverted you know then
you need to find like an introvert and
then you know because you like balanced
each other out and you like draw out the
best in each other and then you come to
get you know I mean you can see where we
kind of have this like difference thing
it's like and then it's like magic and
it just works out beautifully all the
time you know
um yeah the couples the extrovert
introvert couples are laughing and
they're holding it in inwardly they're
like maniacally laughing Ah that's the
most insane thing I've ever heard
um right because it's actually well in
essence it's funny though we often don't
look at someone like you know they're
thinking about like oh no I'm thinking
about dating or whatever well we often
Our advice is sort of elaborate stuff
it's it's often not something as basic
as like
find someone
really good
someone you can trust
isn't it sort of strange that we're
often not like we're sort of like I
don't know maybe it's because we think
it's a given I don't know but we have
these elaborate theories you know like
okay find the perfect personality
um and I think something similar kind of
happens with gender where
um we kind of have this idea of like
okay of what it is to be a man or
masculine or you know female and
feminine and we kind of have these
theories
um and it's often actually quite hard to
articulate exactly what is that you know
and the more you do it the more you
realize like well like okay it doesn't
always apply but sometimes you know
um but nonetheless we have these
theories you know and so we say like
well
you know this is like the the foundation
of marriage it's like these it's these
differences you know it's it's like the
the gender difference and then you bring
them together and they like balance each
other it put it however you want you
know balance each other out or the
strength of one draw kind of counter
bounce the weaknesses of the other and
you know so on and so forth
and I think we often in the church
really I'm speaking broader now about
the broader church I think that often we
kind of root that those ideas
um or we draw them I think largely from
a passage like uh the one we
just read so the man gave names to all
the livestock the birds in the sky all
the wild animals but for Adam no
suitable helper was found so the Lord
God caused the man to fall into a deep
sleep while he was sleeping he took one
of man's ribs clothes at the floor God
made a woman from the river taken out of
the man he brought her to the man and so
folks will say like ah CC right there
there you go
I carry you know it's like it's the
difference it's the personality
difference it's the gender difference
it's the you know all the difference
and uh and they come together you know
um and they you might even say they kind
of complement one another
now last week we focused on some very
different passages it was the the
somewhat Infamous um they're known
um among people as the clobber passages
and thinking you know Leviticus 20
um 13 Romans 1 which if you're familiar
with them we're not going to rehash them
you can go back and listen to that
message
um but something I named was that uh
largely at kind of the you know if you
if you guessed where the conversation
was based on Facebook among Christians
you would think
um it's you know well it is at least
there on Facebook it's all about the
clobber passages but we named last week
that actually Scholars have largely kind
of moved on from those in terms of
really rooting and basing their
arguments in that like they'll mention
them but it's it's just not really where
all the light and heat and passion is so
this is what we named last week which
kind of maybe left some of you wondering
like okay so it's not those passages the
ones all my friends are posting on
Facebook
um what what where is the conversation
going and the answer is
right here
uh it's it's largely
now Genesis to some degree one but
mostly this Genesis kind of two
passage and
um
this is where basically the kind of
traditionalists this is someone who
um
says basically someone who holds to that
that same-sex unions are like not
blessed by God or something that's a
traditionalist and what they say is like
whoa see I I understand like Leviticus
and Romans 1 and for all the reasons we
named last week why those are kind of
problematic uh but I don't I don't know
what I see how you get around
Genesis one and Genesis 2 this passage
we just read like I don't how how can
you how can you do that
um and yet it was in Reading
um a number of different thinkers I
mentioned Karen Keane last week those
kids are excited in there
um and I'll mention her again this week
um really helped me see it's amazing how
we often don't realize we're
interpreting the Bible until someone
offers a different interpretation and
kind of blows our minds you know it's
like it was right there all along how
could I not see it but I couldn't it's
it's amazing how we often think well I'm
just reading I'm just reading the text
I'm just reading the text of scripture
for it's plain meaning aka the one that
immediately sprung to my mind
not necessarily the one that's you know
especially you start Crossing cultures
and all of a sudden it's like completely
different words images jump out at them
you know I mean that I'm like what why
are you focusing there clearly we shall
Focus here you know
um we just don't realize how we are
we're interpreting all the time you know
and I it wasn't until reading them that
I realized like oh wow I've I have I've
been interpreting this and I think the
key verse is uh verse 23. the man said
this is now bone of my bone and Flesh of
My Flesh she shall be called woman
for she was taken out of man
and what's interesting there is that
Adam does not break out into an
elaborate essay on gender difference and
as the scholar biblical Scholars say
complementarity he doesn't say like oh
my gosh
it's it's eve
I cannot believe how utterly different
unique in every way I mean it's like
it's like I'm from Mars and she is from
Venus and it's like I don't even know I
don't even know how can we hi I'm Adam
you know like I don't even know how it's
gonna work you know uh that's not what
is did you notice actually it's the
exact opposite
that's the thing that blew my mind like
I was it was right there
but I couldn't see it he doesn't
emphasize the difference what does he do
the way
um Karen Keane puts it she says a
turning point comes
when God creates woman directly from
Adam's Body right so there again you
have this deep this closeness this
intimacy
the man wakes up and immediately
exclaims this is now not oh so different
no this is now bone of my bones
Flesh of My Flesh
he Delights in her similarity
to him
I think to kind of put in my own words
I may say that the foundation of
marriage
is not different personality different
difference gender different whatever
kind of difference you want to interject
I say the foundation of marriage is
actually sameness and similarity what do
I mean by that I mean our shared
Humanity
our shared Humanity our covenantal love
you are now bone of my bone and Flesh of
My Flesh we are human beings this is why
it's contrasted right with the the
naming of the animals
right and that's what Adam's going
through all these animals he's like oh
this isn't going to work
you know but then it's oh this is now
bone of my bone Flesh of My Flesh in
fact
um
later in the Book of Genesis
we see a very similar turn of phrase
used although this time it's not in the
context of a marital relationship
instead it's actually a father-in-law
son-in-law dynamic
this is Genesis 29 verse 14. uh and
Laban said to Jacob you certainly are
my bone and my flesh
you see they're The Echoes of Genesis 2
27 chapters earlier
but it's it's two men uh father-in-law
son-in-law friends
connected
um
their families now connected through
marriage you are now my bone and my
flesh
in other words well I think um certainly
orientation
plays a part right we need to be drawn
to the other attracted to the other
in the end it's it's not some elaborate
theory of difference in the end it's
it's our shared love it's our shared
Humanity it's actually the fact that oh
I can relate to you
I can relate to you I do I I can start
to Intuit like what you're thinking what
you're feeling because I'm human too and
I know what it is to be human and so
this becomes the foundation of our
connection and our relationship I think
it's like it's right there and just it's
beautiful
it's beautiful
in other words I think we often ask the
wrong questions
you know like is my personality the
perfect match
for him for her for a week could this
really work because I don't know on the
Myers-Briggs I'm an INT and I'm an
Enneagram too and they're you know like
Okay
um
in the end maybe we should be asking am
I drawn to them
am I drawn to them and am I oriented
towards them and are they good
not perfect
are they good and trustworthy and
someone I can like build with
like maybe maybe those are the questions
that we should be asking because the
foundation of marriage is not difference
the foundation of marriage is actually
sameness and similarity it's our shared
Humanity it's our covenantal love
many of you know that
I live
um very much in in community
uh I live my wife and I and our three
kids we live downstairs with my brother
and sister-in-law and their four kids
they live upstairs and we share the
kitchen and living room and so my house
is loud
and um but because of this it's one of
the really cool things is I get like a
front row seat to the marriage of Josh
and Mindy Reynolds my brother and
sister-in-law I did ask their permission
to share this by the way and um
they have y'all
they have a good marriage and then you
know honestly in this day and age that's
a beautiful thing like don't take that
for granted you know and um I was like
thinking about like what is it what is
it that like makes their marriage kind
of work and
um you know I don't it's it's not that
they have like some perfect personality
match
um they are both similar in ways and
then wildly different in ways and you
know
um it's not because they had children
you know
um though they did I guess that's
awesome you know
um
but I I think what is it like I think in
the end they not only made marital vows
about two decades ago
but they do the daily work of showing up
and keeping them
they are present I don't just mean
literally in the house
they are emotionally available to one
another and when the stuff hits the fan
and no friends sometimes it does doesn't
it as it does for all of us I'm not
picking on them it does this for all of
us
um they're there for one another
they're there for one another you are
now bone of my bone and Flesh of My
Flesh
I think also of
Janine Horton in Leslie Irwin their
travelings they couldn't be here tonight
or um Leslie's working and um
but they're the table Zone they're great
if y'all know them like they're just a
wonderful wonderful couple and I don't
live in community with them so I don't
have like quite the front row seat I
have been in their home and I've gotten
to know them quite well in the past like
year year and a half that they've been
here
um and I guess they have you know they
have things that are similar uh they
both like cats
and I guess that's a good thing
um but I also know they're like super
different uh they I know Johnny is quite
extroverted and Leslie not so much
um but I don't think that's like some
magical you know
um
instead why why does it work
I think in knowing them if you know them
at all you know that they're both deeply
committed
to their own emotional spiritual growth
and health
and it doesn't mean they're perfect just
like Josh perfect
um but it but it means they're but
they're committed to that Journey
and the way it plays out in their
relationship is that they support one
another they love one another
and they happen to be the same gender
but but in the end it's it's that
um deep love and commitment you are now
bone of my bone Flesh of My Flesh it's
that kind of
um connection
that is the basis for their Union
and so what I want to start doing here
at the table or maybe not start we've
already begun
um but I want to continue to make space
make room
for all of us
because often what happens is is when
the church has focused on
gender complementarity and then with
that is often the notion of like
procreation then becomes like the kind
of part of the Bedrock of marriage what
this did as you all know is begins to
leave a lot of people out even like in
Fertile couples
become sort of like well that's not like
really a real mayor you know and and I
think that kind of theology
um I think it's just proven itself
unhelpful
and so I'm looking forward to a new day
a new day in the church and and the
table's not alone in this at times it
feels like we're alone but we're not uh
there are others and I just I look
forward to date I don't know 10 20 30 40
years from now
um when
all sorts of people can come into a
church space and feel like there's room
for me
and there's room for the people that I
love
the person I love there's room for my
marriage in all of its beauty and
complexity and crazy just like it is for
all of us
um I longed for that day
and so uh we'll consider this another
step on that path that sound good
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we take in the body of Christ in the
bread the blood of Christ in the wine
it's it's a moment for
us to re-center on Christ for us to even
renew our own commitments our own Love
Of Christ it's interesting in the
scriptures God often speaks to us in
like marital metaphors that he has
bonded himself to us he's connected he's
committed to us and so as we come
forward to participate in communion
that's what we get to participate in
again what we get to it's a moment of
connection in co-nunion with Christ
so on the way we'll do this we'll start
with the front rows and we'll kind of
work our way back we practice what's
called an Open Table meaning if you're
here tonight and you would like to
participate there's something in you
that's drawn to know Jesus to connect
with Jesus maybe you're like I don't
know if I have all my theology worked
out uh that's okay if there's something
in you that wants to connect with the
Risen Jesus then feel free to come
forward and participate having said that
there's no Stigma you know if you can't
or don't want to that's okay too
um the red is wine the white is grape
juice so
I'll just know
and then finally you can just partake
whenever you'd like no one will kind of
lead you through the exact moment to you
know partake the elements you can take
it immediately or return to your seat
and protect there so this is the table
not at the church
but of the Lord
and it's um oh my gosh I just forgot
this I've done this every week for like
two years
and it's made ready for those who love
him
and for those who want to love him more
so come you who have much faith and you
who have little
you have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed come
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here come to
the table
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're going to close out tonight with a
song if you were here last week actually
you sing it then as well
um it's going to sort of be our theme
song for our Sticks and Stones series as
it still represents I feel like the
heart that we're going for here in our
literal table community and the table
as as the church and what we would like
for it to be so if you guys would stand
with us
we're gonna sing for everyone born
[Music]
let's all sing this together
shelter in Space
the safe place
[Music]
passion and peace
of Justice
Justice and joy
[Music]
asking for genders diverse
food gender's diverse
a place
[Music]
with wisdom and Grace
dividing the power
put genders diverse a system that's fair
and God will Delight when we are
creators of Justice
[Music]
compassion and peace
of Justice
Justice
[Music]
a place at the table
Covenant chair a welcoming space
[Music]
of gender and colors
Volcan for straight The Chalice of Grace
[Music]
Justice and choice
you all for being here if you are new
please on your way out fill out one of
our visitor cards it's in the hallway on
the little tiny table uh if you could
fill that out put it in the Box that'll
just give us a chance to follow up with
you and answer any questions that you
might have uh also we are really
committed to being an inclusive
christ-centered community and generosity
is a big part of that so if you would
like to join us in that mission you can
give financially also in that little box
in the hallway or you can go to the
tabletx.org and give online there also
if you are in need of prayer a hug or
just general support please come find me
after the service I would love to be
there for you however it's needed
um
anything else I think I covered the last
announcements yeah and then my favorite
part the men addiction you're all
standing feel free to put your hands out
in a just a receptive nature these are
words that I believe are true for every
single one of you here in this room and
those who are watching online
you are a child of God
are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace compassion and unconditional love
to everyone you come in contact with
have a great week we hope to see you
back here next Sunday be blessed good
night
[Music]
and God will Delight when we are
creators of justice and joy
compassion and peace
[Music]
just